[Musique]
henry
celia ça fait longtemps
qu'ils ont ouvert les livres sur le vol 127.
les pirates de l'air ont eu de l'aide de l'intérieur de notre
station ici à vienne
nous devons savoir si nous avions un moule
[musique] la
victime me fait regarder en vol  127.
donc c'est une interview
je pensais que tu étais là pour voir si nous
avions encore cette vieille étincelle
avec de vieux amis
oh tu peux faire mieux que
ça  127 s'est produit,
le détournement semble avoir pris le
plus tragique
quelqu'un dans notre station nous a trahis et
vous,
ils m'ont vraiment innocenté
si nous avions commencé à crier mo, cela
aurait été tout pour nous tous, nous examinons
les preuves que nous suivons les faits êtes-vous
accusant  moi
nous voulons garder ça silencieux nous ne pouvons pas nous
permettre l'embarras d'une
poursuite si c'est celia harrison
j'ai besoin de savoir que l'homme que j'envoie peut faire
ce qui est
nécessaire  ça doit arriver maintenant
ce sont les choses que nous ne savons pas qui
me touchent
[Musique]
ce que nous avions était réel
n'est-ce pas
toi